[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's going crazy
uh
hey guys we're here somewhere in africa
and we're gonna do a sand boarding
competition so we don't know what we're
doing
the wind is crazy here but we're going
to go these dunes we're going to have a
practice round
and then we're going to have a round
where we're going to see who's the
fastest we're going to have a
competition
let's go so for balance mostly we tell
people to do this
use your arms raise your arms like this
and you bend your knees like this
[Music]
just go sit just pull down
you have to avoid pulling on front okay
yeah yeah trying to fall like a baby you
have to sit yeah yeah
okay so that's three and you two and
then the winner
right we're going together yeah okay
[Music]
so renee is going first he's the
youngest mute
you guys ready yeah yes ready
so
[Music]
so
three
[Music]
[Music]
get the whole offer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
too extreme but isn't that what our team
is extreme team
this is very snake ready yeah i'm going
standing there
all right guys we had time to fall a lot
especially me
practice now time for competition we're
gonna go down here see who's the first
guy
on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
five four three
two one
[Music]
one eternity later
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys was a tough day but the
winner
is mute grenade well done yeah
we got all the march of the battles
especially grumpy over here look at his
face
this is how good you already do it
see you guys in the next video